This is the Chris Abraham show.
Welcome to the Chris Abraham
show season four episode octane
octane 18 and I am here in a
windy.
Windy day in a windy, windy Park
filled with cars going by and
people in Burrs and yap.
Yap, yap adapt and so I
apologize.
I do have a dead cat on my Sony
WS. 85 Re recorder.
And I am reaching out to you
today to report on just one week
of carnivore diet and getting
back on the rowing machine.
And the reason why I'm so
motivated to talk about it today
is because tldr what is it
called?
Spoiler alert my knees don't
bother me.
I'll be right.
Back talk to you soon.
Welcome back to season 4 episode
18.
My name is Chris Abraham, and I
wanted to tell you that I've
been on, I've been on a
carnivore diet now, for Six
Days, Seven Days and I am
regular, which something I was
extremely afraid about afraid of
Freedom, not be Secondly, my
knees do not feel all messed up
at all at 333 pounds and six
foot three.
I hate my knees, but I believe
that most of that had to do with
inflammation and I should have
known because when I was a
little boy, my parents had to
deal with the fact that I was
always sneezing and always my
nose is always running and I
always had sinus drip and I was
always stuffy and My parents
took me to an allergist in
Kailua across the poly from Oahu
Honolulu, where I where I lived
and and they did a prick test
and that has nothing to do with
my nether regions that has to do
with my my arm, they would prick
me with different different
things that I might be allergens
things.
I might be allergic to and turns
out I'm allergic to everything.
Including or excluding plumeria,
but I should have known that if
I'm that easily allergic and
that completely allergic to
everything that my lungs, and my
nose and my sinuses inhales and
breathe from the world.
Then I'm probably allergic to
loads of stuff that I consume
and now And I'm only eating eggs
beef.
Butter toffee water, Sometimes
some pickles, even though that's
not strict.
I feel really good and I'm on
Reddit right now in a.
So if you go to reddit.com slash
U /, Chris Abraham, you'll see
that I'm talking to people about
in the carnivores, sub about how
easy it is to get full on the
carnivore diet that just like
eating that much meat.
Or just only me to kind of makes
me feel a little nauseated.
Not because I care about the
sort of The Souls of poor little
animals, I don't.
But for whatever reason, I could
eat, you know, fries and chips,
and beans, and rice, and all
that kind of other stuff, all
day long, I can eat, lentils,
and curries.
And, but if I eat, you know, a
big meal of ground, beef and
butter and eggs, little hot
sauce.
Ice and salt and pepper.
I'm done.
And I'm like, so what are the
arguments that we're having on
the Reddit, not arguments?
One of the discussions we have
as whether or not as to whether
or not you need to drink more
water under carnivore diet or
less, or only when you're
thirsty my little app called
Simple.
App is an intermittent fasting
app and it was Me to drink a
gallon of water a day.
Once me to drink 100, 55 ounces
a day but also I am 333 pounds
and six foot three so maybe I
should drink a gallon of water a
day.
Maybe in order to feed all of my
ginormous fat ass fat cells.
Maybe I should definitely be be
drinking that much water to
compensate, so I don't know, but
I do know that I'm thinking that
maybe drinking, that much water
helps, with the helps with the,
the movement through the system
and out the other end, I'm
extremely afraid of that.
But I think what does that is
things like cheese and you know
other types of things like Dairy
and stuff, who knows?
But I am taking a fiber
supplement but not a fiber
supplement that has any type of
sugar or anything.
I'm just taking that type of
fiber supplement that's just
like some sort of husker shell
or something and that's it.
So I'm taking that I'm taking
multivitamins, I'm taking my
prescription.
Yesterday, had a little
container bone broth, beef.
Bone broth.
That was awesome.
I might do that again.
Today later, I'll stop by Giant
and get myself a big bottle of
beef, bone broth.
And that's how it's going my.
But I might, it might not be
100% the diet.
Like I've started making sure
that I'm on the rowing machine
every day.
I'm not up to it 60 minutes a
day, which is what I aim for my
gold.
My golden Baseline is 60, Slow
Rolling minutes a day, and if
you want to see, I'll try to
keep all that stuff.
If updated on reddit.com slash
are slash slow.
Rowing if you're interested,
please join me there.
But, you know, basically I'm
rowing at 22 to 24 Strokes per
minute.
At around 3 minutes to 3
minutes, 20 per 500 meters.
And sometimes when I lose
myself, and I'm really into
television, Sure movie, it'll
get down to 2 minutes, 50
seconds per 500 meters.
And when I really get used to
it, and I kind of get extremely
comfortable with the gold
standard of 60 minutes.
I am going to start adding, you
know, in the rowing World, in
crew, they call that kind of
meterage, that kind of work.
They call it steady state where
I would do, you know, two
minutes 5460.
Minutes going for, you know,
mean everybody.
Who's anybody involved with
Concept twos is connected via
urgh data which is an app and
that urged data, app connects to
my Performance monitor, 5:00
p.m. 5:00 device via Bluetooth
and that logs to log dot concept
to.com.
So it logs every meter that I do
which of course right now goes
towards the.
Is it the full challenge?
Right now but doesn't matter.
I want to do an hour every day
and that to me is around at
least during the start a little
under 10,000 meters a day, as I
become stronger and more
comfortable with the rowing.
It'll probably be more like
15,000 12,500, something like
that.
And if I add power tends, power
20s which is basically rowing
for pulling as hard as I can for
fifteen or twenty five Strokes
or you know, 2013 actually you
know like pulling hard for 10
Strokes or Twenty strokes.
But then there's like not
included in those ten Strokes.
X is what's called an up one up
two.
So it ends up being 12 hard
Strokes, maybe 22 art Strokes.
If you add the two strokes that
are dedicated to ramping up from
steady state into hard stroke.
So adding those I think twenty
Strokes would be really good for
all the things that
high-intensity gives to your
body.
It's you know it's an
abomination.
Lick as opposed to aerobic.
No it's sorry, it's anaerobic as
opposed to aerobic.
Oh by the way, yesterday when I
said interior chain, I guess so
but I meant posterior chain.
The posterior chain is the part
of your body that is activated.
When you do kettlebell swings,
it is also most of the, the
nervous system and muscular
chain that is Is triggered
activated when you do, when you
do, when you row on a sliding on
a sliding seat on a sliding seat
rower?
I guess, it's also if you're in
a row boat or whatever, but it's
more along the lines, if you
really get your hamstrings, your
glutes, your lower back, your
upper back your scapula, Etc,
so, Really exciting about these
knees.
I must tell you that there seems
to be a direct correlation with
not being in pain and being
generally more active.
So the lesson pain you are, the
more active, you'll be willing
to become the letter.
You are the more likely you are
to to be active?
The better.
You are.
The more likely you are to be
fitter.
So It seems to me that Fitness
is a game of hockey stick.
We're at in the beginning,
you're, it's really challenging
but as you start to become more
fit and more mobile and more and
and in less pain.
It means that you'll be doing
more standing more walking, more
running more climbing, Then you
will be, if you're in pain,
you'll spend more time standing
and sitting and lying down.
So if you can find a way whether
it's through diet or physical
therapy, or getting onto a
running machine and working on
range of moment, exercise rate,
range of movement exercises,
like on the rowing machine or
leg extension, I've always found
in terms of lubricating Knees.
Getting onto getting into a gym
and on a leg extension machine
has always been really good for
my range of movement.
And for my Mobility with regards
to my creaking, he's you should
do it because if it on the other
hand, my CrossFit buddy, my
business partner Dan Krueger, he
tells me that at his level of
eight pack, eight pack, super
trap, super deltoid, super Pacs,
Super quads, he tells me that in
the last 10 years, he's always
been sore.
So all I can say to him is fuck
that I don't want to be sore
every day.
I don't mind being sore a little
bit of the day or tired, a
little bit of the day but I
don't want to be constantly
sore.
So I think that moderate
exercise is going to be my
pathway into a longer life in a
better future rather than high
intensity.
Extreme intensity exercise ever
will be anyway, we'll be right
back with season 4 episode 18
closing, right after this.
Oh thank you.
Welcome back.
Welcome back, welcome back.
This is Chris Abraham.
The Chris Abraham show formerly
known as Chris cast season 4
episode 14.
My name is Chris Abraham.
He says we're definitely you can
reach me at Abraham .su you can
reach me at Chris Abraham.com.
You can reach me at
calendly.com.
Chris Abraham, / 15.
You can signal telegram or
what's that mean?
You can text me, or you can call
me at +1, 20 to 35, to 50 51.
You can find me at twitter.com
slash Chris Abraham,
facebook.com slash, Bruce
Abraham, Youtube.com slash
Chris, Abraham instagram.com,
Chris Abraham linkedin.com in /,
Chris Abraham, Chris Dash
Abraham.com is my Tumblr No
Agenda show.
Sorry.
No Agenda social.com at Chris is
me Guerra Vic .s U / at Chris's
me if you go to give Vic .s you
can sign up for an account I
believe Macedon account.
Aunt and follow me there.
I would love it if anybody join,
if anybody follow me there,
currently nobody listens to me
in the entire world, even though
a woman who goes to my Cafe
thinks that I'm and my best
friend.
My mother didn't think I was
funny or anything.
interesting at all.
Supposed to be your mother who
loves you.
But my my buddy Mark and my my
friend from from ID toes, they
both think that I'm the
funniest.
The entire world.
And while I think that's only
because they adore me.
And because I've got their funny
bone and in the fact that they
are Charmed by me, through
whatever Through Chemistry.
But if you think that's true
too, please give me a review.
Give me some Stars.
Give me some love.
Give me some money.
Give me some jobs.
Give me some gigs and I'll talk
to you soon.
Lots of love to you soon.
Love you.
Bye.
Thank you for listening to the
Chris Abraham show.
Make sure you subscribe.
So you don't miss any future
episodes until next time.